What's up everybody, we're Pongfinity!
Todaywe're putting our coaching skills to the test
as our guest stars Roni Bäck and Robin Packalen
will be playing one match against each other.
And the winner will get this amazing Pongfinity
showdown trophy.
We have one hour time to teach them how to play, lets get into it.
Good luck Miikka!
Good luck!
So the big day has come, Roni is with me now
and we're going to take ourone hour session.
I have to say this is a fanboy moment
I have watched your videos since the early days and now I'm here.
Thanks Roni!
So team Robin.
Here I am.
Yeah you ready forthis?
I'm totally not ready for this but um...
Let's at least try.
I have played ping pong onVR but
now it has been like five years since I last played in real life.
Oh so this is gonnabe interesting!
So we've got one hour time, lets get you prepared.
Yeah!
There's a racket.
Thank you.
Let's just start like seeing what's your level.
Oops opps too much power.
How do you grip yourracket?
With two okay.
How do you hold the racket?
I don't know just like this I guess.
Normally Iuse the VR controller so I'm not sure how to..
You can try if this feels better.
This? Yeah. Like this.
Sort oflike shake hands with the racket.
Oh really? Yeah.
As long as you win this match
that's the only thingthat matters.
That's true that's true.
Is it better?
I think it might actually be a little bit
better.
Yeah there's no way we're gonna lose this!
I feel like I'm doing nothing basically.
YeahI'm just hitting to your racket.
I'm trying to build your confidence you know.
Backspin, backspin.
I'll put a bit backspin to you also.
Oh what do i do now!
If the other one puts backspin youcan also try to just put backspin.
You can try to go uh more forward.
Guide the motion more towards where you're hittingit.
Then you can hit it faster.
That's good!
I have my penhold serve.
Oh this is good!
A bit of sidespin there.
A lot of sidespin!
Give me your best serve.
You're supposed to do do it like this right?
Yeah do like a motion or something.
That was so bad!
Okay we can work on it.
Does Miikka have some kind of special trick that he
could have taught to Robin?
I think there might be some kind of serve.
If we get your serveto be good then we've got a good chance against Roni.
I'll try to demonstrate somekind of serves that might be coming for you.
Start with these.
So that's like..
Very good, nice!
To be honest I tried to hit that side.
Oh that's good. That was a good one.
You got it you got it!
Excellent return.
Nice!
If you let it drop a bit lower,
then it's going to be..
But that was that was a little bitbetter.
So the faster this movement is, the more spin you get.
Try to really like kind of like hit it like that like fast with the wrist.
Yeah that's that's better!
Yeah a lot more spin.
Oh that is better.
Try and get it as deepin the corner as you can.
Nice!
That was a really good serve.
Yeah that was one of the best.
Like this isour number one serve
Yeah!
Official balls!
Pongfinity 40 plus.
It's the best ball in the world!
Really? Yeah!
Because it's our own ball.
Obviously.
Nice ooh nice nice nice!
What is going on!
Good, that's so good!
I'm just generating all the ping pong talent from here.
I know what we stillhave to try.
The around the net shot!
Ooh close close.
Nice!
That counts that counts.
Yees! That was low.
Okay we're gonna end there because that was so good.
Yeah that was a good one!
I think I think we'vegot this.
Yeah me too yeah.
You can learn quite a lot in one hour.
I'm pretty confident now!
Atleast I feel very very confident right now.
The winner will go home with this amazingtrophy.
Ooh that actually looks amazing.
Shinyyy.
I have a spot for it.
Lets see who wants it more!
You look like you you want it more!
You're serious!
Remember one thing,
that is around the net!
You have to get onearound the net and that's our day is complete.
Okay I didn't expect that but lets go with it!
Aroundthe net!
Lets go lets go lets go!
Ready for this?
I'm so nervous!
No you got this you got this!
Oh yeah.
Lets do this! All right!
Come on come on!
There!
You try to kill me!
To all my Chinese fans.
Ooh what a spin! Sidespin!
Oh not again not again!
Good backspin good backspin!
It's like a chop, did you teach him how to chop?
You went for it that's rightthat's right!
Nice serve what a sidespin, incredible sidespin!
I don't know what happened but it worked.
Take it easy!
Around the net!
That's what we practised!
First set 11-5 to Roni.
Great job!
That went just according toplan.
Around the net and you made it!
That was the only thing I was thinking of.
Yeah I saw I saw.
He was much better than I thought.
But that was only the first set, it's not overyet.
If he hits backspin, you hit backspin.
If he hits topspin, you hit topspin.
Thenerves, the nerves!
Keep going keep going!
We got this!
All right come on!
Come on let's go!
Soon you will be mine.
There!
Nice serve!
He's just lucky Robin.
A good player has good luck.
Nice, nice!
Time out. Time out?
Yeah.
This is going just according to plan.
I'm going to be completely honest with you now.
Yeah tell me.
It's not looking very good for us.
It is not.
But not hopeless.
This is the worstsituation to be at.
Just a bit of a lead.
Just think whenever you're serving,
only do this serve.
Nothing else.
Come on!
Nice serve, nice serve!
Yeah I think it touched.
It touched!
Touched the net yeah.
Noo way!
Honestly it touched!
It touched!
Check it from your..
Miikka it was this much over.
It wasn't even like..
Get back to your chair!
It touched.
It clearly touched!
Yellow card!
Nice! Good one!
Nine all.
Roni, special serves!
Which one of those.
You got this!
It wasn't that hopeless in the end.
Crazy comeback! You know how nervous I was?
Like this nervous.
6-3 situation is the worst.
Yeah it was dangerous.
He's playing quite defensive like he's notattacking very much.
So you just go for an attack.
Now you were very passive.
If you stay closerto the table
then you have a better position to start playing harder yourself.
Everythingthat we talk here I forget there.
All right let's hit it.
Same strategy.
Come on! Last set.
We got this.
Deciding set. Roni to serve.
Come on come on!
Come on Robin lets go!
Nice! Perfect that was perfect!
Aah good serve!
There it is!
Kärpäslätkä!
Change sides now.
Okay now you get the betterside.
It's good now this is the better side.
No no no i don't like this.
What more do you want!?
Where did that come from?
We didn't even practice that!
I have watched your videostoo much.
Like honestly very very good.
What is going on!
Good saves good saves though!
Nice!
Nooo!
10-9, matchpoint!
10-10, two point difference.
Nice!
One point!
Robin remember the serve.
Yyeess!
Thank you audience! Thank you!
Nice!
We got this!
Ooh it's empty.
It was a good match.
This is the biggest trophy that I have ever won!
Thank you for my coach for believing me
Even though I didn't that!
That was an incredible match!
Thank you good match, well played.
Thank you my opponent.
Well coached!
Well played!
Go and check out both Roni's and
Robin's YouTube channels!
Congratulations to the winners!
And huge thanks to Roni and Robin
for joining us today
Any day, any day!
Subscribe!
Or I hit you with the ping pong ball!
Can I keep the bandana?
Of course!